during this hour off is Monique in New
York hi Monique how are you hi I'm good
things how are you better than I deserve
what's up so I'm a pretty new listener I
just recently started actually saving my
money and I was working on starting my
emergency fund and was wondering if it
would be in my best interest to still
sell a car that I have that kind of
breaks down pretty often and cost me a
lot of money so I was wondering if we
just make more sense for me to sell it
and buy like a $3,000 car or something
like that so what do you owe on the car
that you're driving nothing what's it
worth on the high end eight thousand and
how much debt do you have not counting
the car well you don't have any on the
car do you have none no doubt at all no
so you're trying to just get on a budget
and save money and the cars breaking
down a lot yes okay do you know other
than the fact that it's giving you some
trouble do you like the car yeah I like
it a lot my first car got it for my
birthday kind of attached to it but at
the same time if it's gonna cost me more
then you know how old are you 22
what'd you say your income was um I make
roughly 1,800 a month
um I got twenty thousand dollars a year
you're still living at home I'm living I
have a roommate right now so rent is
pretty cheap I just graduated I don't
really have a direction yet so I'm kind
of at like a random job working right
now Oh got you okay what's your degree
in biomedical sciences okay all right
well what happens to all of us when the
car breaks down more than a couple of
times is we get pissed off it's
inconvenient and it just get mad at the
stupid thing and what happens if you're
not careful is that'll cloud the actual
mathematics of the situation just
because you
get so mad you're just like I'm dumping
this thing you know so what I would do
is to get past that a little bit I would
go back and itemize and make a list of
the actual dollars that you're spent on
the car in the last 12 months go over
well over ten thousand it's well that's
not only 12 months in but overall the
cars cost me over ten thousand I just
went down and you aren't that down and
itemized that my calculated there I've
kept the receipts from the mechanics and
stuff
you spent $10,000 on an eight that was
another car yeah I did haven't knew it
started having trouble from the
beginning so in the beginning it made
sense but then it kind of added up and
it's not making as much sense to me
anymore how long have you had the car
I'd said 2012 seven years okay all right
and how much have you spent on it in the
last twelve months
mm okay twenty-five hundred roughly yeah
okay but you're saying ten thousand
since 2012 yes okay all right because I
thought my god you just had to rebuild
the whole car second I don't know about
you like that sometimes yeah yeah okay
what kind of car is it it's a Jeep which
one Patriot okay I just said reading
about them being a piece of junk but um
I nobody told me that until after I had
the car okay I haven't read that you've
read that somewhere or just have to say
that I've had many people when I tell
them that he's just say wow I'm so sorry
well I mean here's the thing in if you
know I have had I've got kids that are
10 years older than you and if one of
them was your age and I was in your
exact situation I might say yeah go
ahead and sell the car but no I would
not buy a $3,000 car you have $8,000 for
the proceeds of this car I would buy a
nice
solid dependable that you've researched
and you've had a mechanic look at for
you before they applied it a car for
$8,000 okay my only concern with that is
that I don't have a job lined up so I
was hoping to save a little bit more to
get myself more cushion well you're
making eighteen hundred a month and you
don't have a heavy expenses so you do
have a job it's just not the job correct
okay so you're gonna be fine I mean you
know if you want to move down to a
$7,000 car and put a thousand dollars in
the bank that's fine but you don't you
know you don't have any payments and you
work an extra job if you want to build
up some money for savings I don't want a
22 year old single lady going down into
a piece of junk when you don't have to
okay you don't have to in this situation
if you told me at $8,000 owed on it I
might move you into $1,000 hoopty
temporarily and just talk to get out
there and scrape and grind and get after
it but um but I really wouldn't know I
mean I get you in a nice solid car
that's dependable and you can get a lot
of car for $8,000 if you watch what
you're doing or $7,000 so I think you're
through with this car emotionally and
and it sounds like it's got a bad
reputation you've research that out so
research out something like a little
Honda Accord or something that's got a
good reputation and get you the best one
you can get something like that for for
a driving stock for the next two or
three years and you don't have to keep a
car your whole life it's just not a
necessity so hey thanks for the call